what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here from the heart of new
jersey the joint is brought to you by
draftkings listen
three weeks have [__]
got five weeks have gone down in the
[__] books and you're still [__]
around
football is back college football is
back it's time to review the tape get
ready for draftking sports book we got
football this week we got [__]
ufc this week we got college football
this week we got the baseball playoffs
and they start tonight with saint louis
against the los angeles [__]
dodgers
but let's talk about football they're
giving new customers a hundred and fifty
dollars instantly if you bet one dollar
on any [__] football game you
heard me white right [__] head to
draftkings sportsbook app right now
download the app better dollar on any
football game nfl and get a hundred and
fifty dollars in free bets instantly who
takes care of you like that draftkings
and uncle joey now if sportsbook is not
available in your state like in
massachusetts draftkings has a huge cash
prizes up for grabs with the uh daily
fantasy contest
listen download the sports book fantasy
it's tremendous they've given away a
million dollars in [__] prizes and
you're sitting there scratching your
head thinking about when do i get my
unemployment check [__] that however you
play draftkings is giving all new
customers a free shot of a million
dollars in total prizes with their first
deposit whether it's draftking
sportsbook app or draftkings fantasy but
what you're gonna do is download the
draftking sportsbook app today let's get
that party started you can bet
tonight the dodgers against st louis
tomorrow night you got pro football and
then the weekend you're the [__] king
just download the draftking sports book
app use promo code joey and get 150
free bets when you place a dollar on any
football game that's promo code joey
this week at draftkings sportsbook app
the official sports betting partner of
the nfl and the ufc now new jersey
indiana pennsylvania colorado west
virginia
only new customers only
minimum five hour deposit a dollar wager
required
one per customers restrictions do apply
see draftkings.com sportsbook for
details now
if you got a gaming palm i don't want
you lurking over here like a spider
it's only going to get worse 1-800
gambler or in indiana called 1-809 with
it but if you're straight
you're solid and there's not going to be
no misunderstandings
download the draftking sportsbook app
today and let's win some [__] money
it starts tonight with the dodgers and
st louis they got a same day get game
parlay tonight you can make some real
[__] money but it starts with you
downloading the draftkings sportsbook
app today the joint is also brought to
you by one of my all-time favorites on
it
the alpha brain black label brought me
back
along with the therapy that [__]
fantastic and at night
you're like joey how do you get to sleep
with all the [__] that's going on in
your life
new mood new mood relaxes you
like no other it's a tremendous
supplement whether it's the shroom tech
alpha brain
shroom tech sport or immune i mean
listen on it's got it all but it's
touched by you
it starts with you go to honor.com right
now
look over the website look over this
great supplements they have beef jerky
elk jerky mct oil they got it all around
it but you're sitting there unfucking
healthy you understand me they got a
shroom tech immune that'll help you they
got a shroom tech sport for working out
long runs whatever you're doing
the alpha brain is just tremendous
it's a supercharged formula
mental processing is at its best and
you'll be so focused you'll be burning
through people's souls but it starts
with you go to honor.com right now and
press in joey
joint or church and get 10 percent off
delivered to your house the best
supplements in the game on it the joint
is also brought to you by freeze pipe
nothing makes you feel like a bigger
loser than hacking up a [__] lung
when you take a bong head
freeze pipe is here to turn all your
[__] pink lung babies into weed
masters let me tell you something
even lee syed who used to cough after
every
[__] little bong hit
doesn't cough anymore with the freeze
pipe why
because it's frozen it's like getting
snow out of a [__] when you're in
colorado i used to get snow and put it
in the bong you could smoke [__]
susquehanna weed and still think it's
[__] tremendous because it takes that
edge off with that cold
moisture you understand me so smoking
weed doesn't have to hurt your lungs
with freeze pipe you get an icy cold hit
every time
the secret to freeze pipe is it comes
with a detachable chamber that you put
in the [__] freezer it's tremendous
the smoke passes through the frozen part
and cools down the smoke as you inhale
it it's like putting [__] ice cubes
in a bung but better it's non-toxic it
freezes faster than water and it stays
frozen longer freeze pipe cools it down
the smoke by hundreds of degrees and
your throat will thank you whether you
hit a pipe
bubbler a bong or a dab
they got it all do me a favor go to
freezepipe.com right now
right now before we even get off once
you finish up at draftkings
go to freezepipe.com
press and code joey and i'm going to
give you 10 off your first order whether
you're into bungs pipes or bubblers this
is the pipe for you that's
freezepipe.com
preston joey and get 10 off
you go deep in the murky waters with
freeze pipe i love you [__]
let's get this podcast started today
it's wednesday we got no time for fun
and games [__]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
october the sixth wednesday unfucking
believable week
tonight you got the dodgers against
saint [__] lewis
i don't know which way to go [__] st
louis won 92 games in a row
the dodgers are the best team and [__]
how can the dodgers
play in the wild card
and they have the best that predicted to
win the [__] world series over the
giants who the [__] knows aren't you
happy i'm into something now instead of
[__] smoking dope and whatever i got
hobbies [__] i love baseball i've
always loved baseball i won't watch a
whole [__] game like last night i
didn't watch the whole yankee red sox
game i'll watch a couple innings just
the [__] well mercy's in the shower
or some [__]
last night i went over to jimmy's and
watch the game tonight i don't know what
i'm doing oh tonight she's got a [__]
game tonight so
there's no [__] dodger game for uncle
joey tonight you know what i'm saying i
gotta go watch my daughter play softball
but it's been a great week
uh i [__] uh you know i love doing
podcasts i love what they stand for i
love everything about them
but sometimes i let them get too [__]
serious
sometimes i just coming on here and
having a [__] goof you know
too bad i don't smoke dope in here
whatever my daughter's upstairs so i
can't be down here acting like [__]
tommy chung
she could smell it right through the
[__] floor but uh
it's all good man we're having a great
week i'm happy
whatever happened last week happened
last week it's in the [__] past
so today i want to just make an easy
[__] podcast so you guys can giggle a
little bit and get your [__] boots
back to you i'm having lisa add on today
it's a little church reunion just us
talking some [__] just to slow down the
week we had a lot of intense podcasts
the last couple of weeks were big time
guests so i just wanted to
chill today just have a little tata day
and hopefully you'll [__] enjoy it if
not i don't know what the [__] to tell
you what i'm saying i'm trying my
[__] best here i'm having a good time
i'm healthy
and i'm here for you [__] whether
or not you [__] like it i don't give
a [__]
enjoy lisa yeah [__]
[Music]
what up johnny cheech
what's up buddy how's it going getting
old brother getting older no
no no [__]
the [__] i used to do [__] in l.a
five days seven days a week i can't do
now
no you're sleeping till 10 o'clock now
you're you're sleeping relaxing
slept till uh seven today but went to
bed at [__] 11 15 you know
damn i go to bed early i get [__] so
stoned
it's
ridiculous
it's ridiculous how much the tolerance
has changed lee
wow yeah my i i'm good on like 100
milligrams now i smoke i know you have
the those freeze pipes i got a couple
freeze pipes they're [__] awesome
i just freeze pipes hit hard they do but
there's maybe
i use the [__] little one that's what
i use holy [__] holy [__]
i tried it one night i didn't want to
roll a joint and i put weed in there and
keef
and my eyeball almost came out i was
like the one-eyed [__] jew did you
put the whipped cream on up her ass yet
no i've been doing it without whipped
cream i gotta watch the calories nah you
got to put the nozzle in her ass oh like
starbucks you ever go to starbucks when
they they don't put whipped cream on the
coffee and then put the lid on it they
put the lid on and then put the [__]
nozzle in the [__] coffee and then
you gotta do the same with the [__]
so it comes out you put a little half of
cherry on there i can't keep that ass
how long have you been eating ass for
like two months
i i gotta give you your credit man
you're when you're right you're right
that was it's tremendous isn't it it
wasn't it wasn't that bad i don't know i
was like we were just having sex and
like it was just like i've never had sex
like this like like it's actually like
it's fun it's like we have a ton of sex
and i just looked at it one day i was
like i had like i had you on my shoulder
pretty much i was like wicked guys
i i gotta do it i just dove in and i
like we joked about it before that i
don't like doing that because and and
she knows about you and like teasing me
about it and i just went right in and
now it's like every day you gotta you
gotta see what it's like doug and your
immune system i don't know how the [__]
he got sick again because i don't ask on
a weekly
i was spitting the flu i was spitting
the flu right in the face i would see
the flu on the street and just spit in
his face [__] you
it wasn't that bad
i hope you list the reading though you
got to have listerine if you're going to
eat ass and [__] listerine has to be
your best friend unless you
your front tooth are turned brown you
know what i'm saying you don't need that
in your [__] life that's how you know
somebody's an ass eater their front
tooth turns a little brown and [__] from
the [__] [__] juice now when you eat
the ass it don't even stink like [__] i
told you it's got a little water no no
no no she showers before
i could shower 20 times put a hose up my
ass and there's still going to be a
little residue of that
[__] smell and but you know what when
you lick a woman's [__] shit's never
smelled so good you know what i'm saying
it smells like like it's like broccoli
like you look at broccoli it smells like
that but it tastes good for some people
i don't eat it's like putting a dick in
your mouth
that's got jizz on it that freeze-dried
and [__]
i hate [__] broccoli i remember i
went to hollywood bowl one time some guy
was eating broccoli next to me i
couldn't i was ready to [__] barf he
had who was eating broccoli at the
hollywood pole you know these [__]
gentiles dog they go to a concert with
[__] broccoli who the [__] does that
you go to a broccoli you go to a concert
to kill yourself not to be healthy you
know what i'm saying the [__]
broccoli was probably drinking kombucha
juice and [__]
you know
[__] god
drinking vodka light
i don't know why people do this [__] the
world is upside down it really don't be
one that gets vaccinated but they snort
coke you know
i don't get it
they don't want to get vaccinated but
they eat ass what's the difference when
you eat somebody's [__] you're
vaccinated that's it oh yeah you don't
even need anybody you're right dude just
breathing their face just give them a
shot of [__] [__] breath
am i good to go in and like yeah
well this is funny
listerine because she has two little
kids so like every time we do that i
have to go like brush my teeth because
like they they are like knock on the
door the whole time like they like we
have to like sneak around it's weird
with kids around and it sucks when
you're eating ass and some little
[__] [__] knocking on the door
and you're like knock on the door again
i'll kill your mother and i'm saying i
dare you to knock it you little [__]
i'll kill your mother
when i first started counting i went
home with a chick one night that had a
kid never again you know you never heard
me talking about that did you no no
because i did it once and then mommy
mommy what's going on in there what do
you think i'm doing i'm [__] mom
relax your dad
you know what i'm saying
your dad's from baltimore jack he went
out for a ride he never came back you
know saying
he went for cigarettes and never came
back you little ugly [__] sucker now you
want to ruin my parade
[Music]
your father took a look at you and said
this kid's going to be a half a [__] i'm
not sitting around here mommy mommy
what's he doing to you i'm pulling the
hair you [__] you're doing coke
your mom don't even love you she's doing
coke sucker
oh my god yeah that was the only time
you did that with her
one time i took a chick home in boulder
after a comedy show
as we walked in the door she's like i
hope you don't mind i have a child okay
well
unless he's sucking dick he's gonna
throw some quarters in my ass i don't
care what's he got to do with me
[__] the next morning we were
snorting coke and [__] i'm all [__] up
jerking off in the ear and he's banging
on the door i want cereal ain't no
cereal it's closed
i got mom tied up you know what i'm
saying i got mom tied up in a brooklyn
basement
like biggie let's face it
oh my god my cheeks aren't joking and
they kept banging on the door and i'm
like go away
oh yeah and she's like i'm [__] up i
can't get your cereal i'm like
what kind of [__] i'm gonna have a
poster at social services now wanting
poster and [__] i can't have the never
get lead never i never even talked about
it eight years on a podcast yeah you
never heard me talking about dating a
girl with kids because i know it's a
[__] night i don't i listen
if i met a girl and the kids were cool
and she was cool i would have probably
ended up with them that thing was a
nightmare that night oh i can't ima i i
got really lucky her kids are really
cool and but i gotta say i look forward
to like 7 30 when when it starts to be
bedtime it's i start i start getting a
little boner sometimes like yes it's
bedtime let's go to bed let's look let's
read you but the kids are cool that's
fun i can't i was thinking about that
though about you
doing the podcast and doing all the
stuff you did with with mercy
like i finally like and i i only see
them two weekends a month like i don't
and they're asleep when i go over there
at night
like the amount of stuff you have to do
from like seven in the morning it's it's
coloring and tag and hide and go seek
and then you have to work like it's i'm
exhausted after that i don't know how
you did all that for so long
you know my friends don't understand
here they're like where the [__] are you
you never hang out [__] i have an
eight-year-old
you forget everybody forgets that they
had an eight-year-old and how
complicated their life was and some
people
skim through it some people get nannies
some peop you know whatever that's fine
that works for you i wanted to be a part
of life
it's a lot of [__] work it's like
marriage it's a lot of [__] work you
got it's a give and take
you know my marriage didn't last the
first time because it wasn't a give and
take i was running around like a [__]
indian
but once you
you know see what marriage entails you
know i can't i would love to hang out
with my friends more but i can't
dump it on my wife you know i got to
take the little events i got to take the
kickboxing i got to help my wife out
whenever i can and i like hanging out
with her so it's not even like a chore
for me
it's not like i'm watching a kid today i
[__] hate it no i enjoy it i've been
hanging around [__] savages
30 years it's nice to be around kids
that just talk to you about whatever the
[__] they talk to you about you know
i know how old is mercy mercy's about to
be nine eight or nine i have to be nine
holy moly
that's so crazy nine years old
that was time moves by fast man and it's
real
you know it was like she's like a year
away from asking [__] creepy
questions
did she google you yet has she i mean i
know she did a little bit in l.a but
like no she doesn't she hasn't she
you're just still dead to her she don't
give a flying [__] about me and my
career that doesn't even and i
and i don't want to be involved in that
do you know what i'm saying she doesn't
care yeah of course not no
she you ask if she wants to see the many
saints go ahead ask her
i don't want to see it and i don't want
her to see it you know i don't see that
[__]
i'm excited to why i'm going to florida
tomorrow to visit my dad we have it all
planned we're going to take some edibles
and watch it when as soon as i get there
he has an 80-inch tv i'm excited holy
[__] oh yeah my dad's fully weird my
dad's the king of retired people he has
an 80-inch tv his bean bag chairs at the
house lava lamps he's doing anything he
wants to do down there
it's really crazy lee it's it's
as much as i don't want to talk about it
i have to talk about
i'm looking at that right now
you know i'm about to turn 59 years old
unless
costco hires me
i don't know what the [__] i'm gonna do
i know you're looking for a little gig
right you've been putting applications
and you're trying to get a little more
security in your life you know i mean uh
you've done all the realm and you see
that this isn't really a secure life
once you have a girlfriend
and you're looking at marriage and
you're looking at things it this
is a weird life because they can't
really handle it they'll tell you they
can't handle it
but they can't handle it six years down
the line she's going to break up with
you well how do you expect us to have a
relationship you're always gone
right so no i mean
for you man you've been working so hard
for so long and it's like you're
what are you gonna do it for five or ten
more years and you never know how much
time you're gonna have left how much
good like you're you're still healthy
you can still do everything
why not enjoy it i mean what's the point
of killing yourself
if you can't spend any of the money you
made or go on vacations or
like i'm steve simone and i were talking
about this the other day it's like
yeah i'd like to be rich but if i could
make if i could make enough money
to where i don't have to worry about it
but i still get to go on a vacation or
or
watch a movie on on a weekend it's like
what else
like i even i honestly had this talk
with my mom the other day like i i moved
out of my mom's place immediately i was
in a car a week after i graduated
college to go to la
i was really nervous about going back
but
if i get a if i when i get a job i even
told her like listen i might just stay
here and like to see if i move in with
this with my girlfriend in a year or a
year and a half i like being here why am
i going to waste money
i like getting to have dinner with my
mom every night
it's like
leaving la showed me like like even when
i was before i met you working in tv
the shift that i worked was either ten
to seven which mean i had to leave at
eight in the morning get back eight at
night or i'd work from seven pm to five
am
how do people have
lives much less families doing that it's
um
i know there's a lot of people happy
doing it and i like i probably could be
happy doing it in some way but
i think there's a lot more to life than
than just working
well
for me
you know
i'm a [__] [__] i love to work you
know i like the work too yeah you know i
love working i love
being busy i love my mind being uh
you know thinking about positive [__]
you know what i could do to be better i
always enjoyed that
as far as comedy's concerned i wanted to
give it a breather
just to see what i really love what i
really
am about it was 30 years and it wasn't
uh
30 years that was part time i trusted my
ass
you know i think before i met you i
think of 97 98
99 2003
those years for me were
non-stop i didn't turn down
anything it was a ten dollar job a
hundred dollar job
a three hundred dollar job you know i
remember coming off the plane and
shooting you know i remember like now i
get off a plane and i like
would call you and tell you i'm done for
the day
when i first got to la i would get off a
plane to go do [__]
to go shoot a tv show to go [__] do
three more spots it's crazy
that i used to take sunday nights off
when i met you to do comedy or we'd do
the podcast
or whatever i never took a [__] night
off
from 91 to
2005 i didn't take a night off
i know that for a fact
but until i got the longest yard i i
gave myself i forced myself
to take time off but until the longest
shot i never took time off
that was 13 years without a night off
do you think that would have changed if
you had a kid
if i would have had a kid i would have
had to learn to work around it but if i
would have had a kid in 95 we wouldn't
be married anymore either
wow
because i love comedy i love comedy so
much until 2007
that i gave up everything around me like
i gave up health i didn't give a [__]
about staying out till four in the
morning and sleeping until seven
i didn't give a [__] about eating after
the comedy store i would eat two times
after the comedy store but he would
andrew i would go to would die somewhere
and then i would go with red band
somewhere you know
i didn't care about my health i didn't
care how fat i got the the
[__] goal was to be funny
to learn how to be funny and to be a
working full-time comic that was it
nothing
i didn't care about bench presses i
didn't care about calories i didn't care
about
you know diabetes i didn't care about
health i didn't care about anything
comedy was first drugs were second life
was third
well you can't
that's no
that's no recipe for a family
no not at all it's amazing it's amazing
how much you've changed that's a recipe
for no family you know and that's what i
didn't have i never had a family
i never had a wife i never had a kid
because of those reasons because comedy
was one
and cocaine and drugs were a tight
[__] second
you know and dating chicks with no kids
was a tight [__] third you know what
i'm saying i don't want no kid knocking
on the door when i'm trying to eat some
ass and [__]
i'm eating my own cocoa crispies
i don't play it was never on that's
that's something i learned from you is
like you never know what's like that's
that you never plan you plan but you
don't have like daily that you don't
like to go past a day i never planned on
dating somebody with a kid i never
planned on being living back in boston
but you gotta say man i'm happy i'm
happy with the way things turned out so
far
you know we never plan anything and we
don't i was talking to my wife when mike
came in today my wife and i were sitting
there talking
and last night our game got canceled so
we went to the football practice our
kids you know my daughter has friends at
their kids playing the football team or
my daughter's friends play on the
football team you know the
nine-year-olds
so we take the chairs we take some
waters we get some potato chips and we
go to the [__] field i don't need no
chips my wife and the parents
and there was a guy i talked to and my
wife asked me today you were talking to
him last night how's he doing you know
he's 35
and he put a bunch of [__] in front of
him to do
like a remodel vacation two kids
you know [__] one kid plays flag
football the daughter plays softball
cheerleads
you know plus
he works in new york city from 11 00 to
7 30 in the morning
god
so a couple weeks ago he just
you know it's the law diminishing
returns
you could put that time in you could do
it but eventually
the [__] reservoir is gonna bust
yeah and it busted
so he's just trying to take the pieces
back so he had to take a week off of
work
on uh holiday pay
and then this week he's got vacation so
he had he had to take two weeks
to get his life situated again because
it had gotten so far out of
between the remodel
this that so i told my wife i go you
that seems like my life
when i met terry when i first met my
wife i was always doing something
and it wasn't until maybe five years
later that my wife said to me what the
[__]
is it
that you're doing let me see your
notebook and i would show her
what i was doing and she would say why
are you doing this gig 50 bucks
why are you doing this gig get rid of
this
get rid of that get rid of this and
because it was the la it becomes the law
of diminishing returns you're doing too
much and you're not getting anywhere
you're just
you know you're just [__] what's that
expression you're just
spinning away putting your [__]
wheels that's it you're really spinning
your wheels you're making a little bit
of progress i'm not saying that there's
no progress to be made in that time
but at the same time you're making a
little bit of progress but you're doing
so much that you're really missing the
[__] point
and that's what i was doing i wasn't
doing that in la before we left l.a you
know i was talking to josh wolfe the
other day
and we were talking about what you and
mikey were talking about before i came
out even the reefer
my anxiety has gone down in the daytime
it's okay for me to hit the weed twice
now you know like if i take two it's off
a pipe
in the daytime it's okay i did it the
other day and it's okay but guess what
i didn't want to do it
wow like i don't like smoking in the
daytime no more what happens when you if
you were to smoke
it's okay i get hungry
i get it oh but it doesn't give you
anxiety like why don't i not like it
what before i had
i was rebounding i had rebound anxiety
so when i would smoke or take an edible
in the daytime it would just blow it the
[__] up oh no okay but now because of
time the anxiety has gone away
so the other day i wanted just to try it
i went to my friends like let me just
try it because he always cooked
something good
so i took two heights two hits off a
pipe and i got high
but reefer now
makes me think of going to sleep
wow i use marijuana not to go to sleep
so
it's like my sleep apnea machine in bed
i don't go to bed to watch tv i want in
my mind to know that when i go to bed
it's to do one thing to get my dick
sucked
or to sleep you know what i'm saying
i don't go i don't lay in bed to watch
tv i don't lay in bed to read
i don't lay in bed to think because i
want my mind
to know that when i go to bed it's to
sleep
and and those edibles don't make you
like it like you used to you had a rule
for me towards the end with the edibles
you're like no more ideas because those
edibles you give they'll give me idea i
i if i take enough edibles i won't go to
sleep oh you have johnny bad ideas you
start calling me with businesses and
[__]
corporations and i can't help it every
time i get it i just i start thinking of
things i can't sleep on it and you can
sleep you just go right to bed the
podcast the squirrel house
clubhouse but yeah i still stand by that
i still stand by almost all my
at this the podcasters clubhouse
that was a bad idea but why throw soft
on the wounds you know what i'm saying
i've had some bad ideas myself
but
uh
yeah my head has some bad i've done some
bad [__] things when i get high
yeah i get high at night i do some
stupid things like i order [__]
band-aids or something like that in the
mail
you know i'll do stupid things i got a
rule here once i smoke or take another
ball i'm not allowed to open up a
computer
oh yeah what are you going to amazon i
had to make a rule man because i start
buying plane tickets the next day i wake
up and
the tickets to [__] tunisia
you know it's leaving in december i got
the dates wrong i got the [__]
i'm done i'm done so like a couple weeks
ago i went online i did something stupid
i bought something stupid no i bought
something i needed it was for the guitar
i needed a stand and then it got lost
and then the [__] amazon didn't have
it
so then i ordered the wrong [__]
stand so it came so i just sent it so
i'm like
i'm not gonna order none that night no
more i'm gonna let my wife order it
from now on there's a rule don't get on
the computer don't do dick
that's i go through the chair and then
at night i got a
ritual now too
i turn the tv off and i sit for 15
minutes
do you meditate what do you do it's like
a light meditation just to get the
[__] out of my brain before i go to
bed because sometimes you hit the bed
and you think about your day and then
you get agitated all over again
so i'm like i gotta i'd made so many
little [__] adjustments just to help
my sleep
people keep saying to me you look so
much better you look thin whatever i'm
not doing dick i'm drinking water and
i'm sleeping eight hours that's it
and i think back of l.a like i look at
my sleep logs from l.a lee they were
horrible you have sleep logs yeah you
write it down your sleep apnea machine
does it my sleep apnea machine does it i
don't like to look at it and i looked at
them the other day wow
how much are you sleeping a month ago
it wasn't too goodly
at the end of the [__] week
yeah no i mean you'd get home any time
you did comedy you'd probably get home
at like 11 12 go to sleep at one and be
up at 6.
i was [__] sleeping like 40 hours and
seven nights
wow yeah that's not good it makes a huge
difference it's not good 38 hours or
something like that it just was not good
you know
so now
i actually got it up to [__] like 55
hours a week 57 hours a week
and you can tell a big difference
yes
i don't need coffee
coffee houses become obsolete in my life
espressos
not even one i live on one cup of
american coffee a day
how crazy is that i love coffee i'm like
any other [__] american
i could drink coffee all [__] day if
you let me you were taking double
espresso shots before you went to the
gym expresso shots with a [__]
cigarette oh my god
i love it i don't even smoke
and i dream of that [__] a nice double
espresso with a joint
maybe two or three bung hits and a
cigarette
oh
jesus you get in the car after that
you're cutting [__] off
telling them to suck your dick that's my
lane
that's mine
[__]
driving with you is like no one else i
love driving with you it's so [__] you
you got to bring a jacket and you got to
bring a water in case you're going to
have edibles but it's [__] you're
going to have a blast oh yeah and i
still [__] have a blast by myself
when i drive the other day i pulled over
because some guy was just decided to i
swear to god he just decided
to get on the side of a two-lane road
okay that's small enough as it is
like if you see these two lanes you're
like i'm gonna die
but this [__] clown decided he needed
to make a [__] phone call
and he gets on you know he pulls over to
the side but he's not really on the side
oh he's three quarters over the [__]
line so there's a line to [__]
chicago to try to get around him
so i'm waiting like 15 minutes and
finally i got to get around them i'm
coming back from kickboxing with mercy
and i stop at the guy and he's talking
on the phone like well you know whatever
like johnny [__] realtor and i go you
[__] sucker and his expression
he just cracked he just stayed there the
guy he was on the phone with must have
hurt him because he just [__] stopped
i'm like you [__] sucker
you motherless [__]
and as i didn't say muddled as [__] i
did but under my breath
i just hit him with the big [__] suck i
had him with the big casino
and about five feet late i realized
mercy's in the back seat i was gonna say
oh [__] i go mercy i'm sorry about that
and she goes what i go i cursed and she
goes you did i don't even know what that
means i go
that's good you don't need to know what
[__] means [__]
you told on yourself oh she's going to
hear oh my god i i don't know if we
called it the last time or not did we
tell on the last episode how you yelled
at the the two cops messing with the
homeless guy that one morning at eight
in the morning
i think i think we were high in the
morning going to the pod i forget where
we were going but these two you were
driving to the doctor or something
oh is that it okay you were driving like
a surgery or some [__] and we were
stoned to the gills
and won the kawenga
yeah around kawenga and burbank
it's this [__] debt street dick van
dyke wouldn't even live on that [__]
street
it's dead
and we're driving on the street it's
monday morning it's eight o'clock and
these [__]
cops are twisted they got their car
twisted really on a monday morning
there's not enough traffic everybody
even martians even mexicans in mexico
will tell you don't drive in california
in the morning
they know it's [__] heavy duty
traffic yeah this [__] had his
car twisted now i love police i don't
like yelling at the cops
but you can't be that [__] stupid
you're not helping the public right now
you're harming the public you're gonna
cause a [__] accident you got people
backed up you're making them late for
work you're not helping the general
[__] public
this is what i get pissed off about i
don't mind them beating up a black guy
or a cuban guy or a chinese guy that
comes into the territory you know what
i'm saying a white dude [__] hit him
in the head with a [__] car run him
over
but you [__]
[Music]
you that's all fun you [__] twisting
up a traffic and you knew you saw that
lane that morning you saw how much cars
they were doing
so i pulled up to the [__] and
i'm like you [__] both of these
cops they're looking around they don't
know where the [__] it's coming from i'm
like you [__] suckers
get it together and i kept yelling i
kept yelling something
yeah yeah moving [__] no because i think
i was driving and you yelled out across
the car and then what about the homeless
guy who came and attacked you you hit
him with the car at the 7-eleven
that was the worst 7-eleven
oh yeah world ladies and gentlemen
this was i almost i saw a girl get
pimped out against her [__] will one
night in there quarter to five in the
morning
i saw some kinky [__] in this 7-eleven
it was not
a good 7-eleven and one day i go there
with my wife i think we were looking at
the office i think we're already at the
office so we're already at the office
and i go to 7-eleven
and i my wife is in the car and i get in
the car and this [__] is saying
[__] to my wife
like you know giving her the finger and
[__]
doing all that [__] with his tongue and
[__] and i get in the car i'm like what
the [__] is this guy's problem she go i
have no idea i go oh get away from the
car he goes [__] you i got all right i
just [__] and put the car in drive and
just rammed him and i hit his [__]
knees and he went back and i pulled the
back and i'm trying to [__] get out
and he runs up to the car
and he [__] oh no he punches the car
the window shatters and his hand he
broke his hand i can't hear the whole
hand go
oh and he's like ah
and i'm like that you get [__] and
i just pulled off i think i ran over his
foot too
he was like steve buscemi in the
sopranos i [__] him up he was limping
with a broken hand oh my god i can't
that was like oh there's never any of
the stories with you driving
i love it i love it
going to that go into the i just i the
ice house sent me a message on instagram
to let me know they're opening back up
and february
yeah and i like those those are probably
my favorite going to the ice house with
you because for a while we did it like
every month on a wednesday for the live
podcast wednesdays and one saturday a
month
new year's eve
yeah oh my god it was the and then the
testicle testaments like that i gotta
say i'm really happy that they're
opening back up because that that ice
house was probably one of the comedy
store is a special place and i love
being able to go to the comedy store but
it was almost i felt like at home at the
ice house they were always so nice
from from the security guys to the
managers to the wave staff the sound
guys like it was it was just so much i
felt like at home there it was so much
fun
lee
yeah i mean listen la was l.a i was
there after 23 years i had a good time
if i was to tell you there was things i
wouldn't miss about l.a i would be lived
here oh there's a lot of [__] and
there's a lot of [__] egotistical
dumb [__]
and there's a lot of pedophiles
and there's a lot of [__] sexual
deviants and all that [__] but i gotta
be honest with you man it's like uh
the people that were good were really
[__] good you know
the ice house was sensational patty
the fight you i don't know if you know
that one manager up there died
no blonde girl passed away during covet
oh no i gave money to her fund from
patreon yeah she died that girl was a
sweetheart to remember what i'm talking
about i think so like chubby blonde kind
of a flat ass but really cute
always brought us water always yeah
cookies and [__] she passed away during
the pandemic i i tell you how guilty i
felt i even called
the fiance
i gave the gofund money and i think i
even threw him a couple yards because
she was sensational you know there was
some sensational people at the comedy
store
there were some great people at the
[__] improv
except for jamie masada i don't know
anybody else at the [__]
laugh factory you know the two
bartenders the asian dudes from thailand
right those guys would ask since i
[__] walked on that
into that comedy club in 1997
you know they were [__] good people
there was some great great
great people who i i definitely still
miss in la you know the agostino
you know i miss steve simone i miss uh
who i spoke to the other night uh
[__] nut you know with eric the beast
what's that the podcast uh
sickler
oh okay ryan rudy rudy there was some
exceptional
[__] people josh potter i know you
miss little josh i see him on instagram
doing his thing he's doing great now
yeah he's like i feel like [__] uh
the dude from goodfellas when i see josh
potter look at josh potter doing up the
town
you know what i'm saying he's out there
he's on the road he's opening for
somebody on the road
these are all guys that i knew
when they were [__] kids like i knew
you when you were kids so i'm i know i
miss felipe
i miss george perez i miss rodrigo
johnny rock
look at darren carter he's at the comedy
store a lot now darren carter look he
sat tight
they wouldn't give him love now
it opened up now he's at the store four
nights a week
yeah you never know what's gonna happen
in this career and that's why you hang
on with comedy
because yeah you had a bad day today but
tomorrow you can hit the lottery the
reason why you got into comedy was to
hit the [__] lottery
so you don't know you just have to stick
it out
you have to be there when nobody else
shows up
i don't care how i you know listen
i could be really ashamed right now you
know i could tell you that
my acting career didn't start to the
sopranos came on tv i
i made a career
out of doubling down on big pussy's back
i could say all those things and
somebody could say that to me
but i know better than that yeah i know
that yes i doubled down on big pussy's
career but you still got to act
to book those roles
you still got to be able to do be funny
to book those roles you still have to
audition well to book those roles just
because you look like look
like somebody
doesn't mean you have a guaranteed role
you still have to do the work i would
still sit with these auditions and
you know go over them for three [__]
hours with a fine toothed comb
just to get these rolls so right and do
they expect you to turn it down like oh
oh my god i'm gonna get roles just by
myself with with nothing no like no they
they're looking for that kind of person
you fit the description you did the work
that's
i'm glad you don't think that way that
would be that i mean that's that's
getting in your own way but it's an
honest way to look at it i've looked at
it other ways like that and yes
but i you know because i'm honest with
myself i have to [__] honestly look
at the mirror
and go how did i get to this place well
the sopranos piggybacked me through big
[__] blah blah blah
but then i just took over you know i got
the longest shot because i didn't look
like big [__] they weren't looking for
big [__] for spider-man 2. right but
what i'm saying is that like mad tv
launched my career you know analyzed
that launched my career i was supposed
to look like [__] and that all helped
and i took it you know listen there's no
small jobs
there's just small actors
you know that's a great way of looking
at it you know
and uh i put the work in i could look at
the mirror and go you know what
i put the [__] work in
you know you know me and mike and i were
talking about music
how when you're starting a band you got
to do cover songs and then you try to
fit in your [__] original music
in between that but people don't want to
hear that because you're not jimmy page
now you're jimmy page and you show up to
you know i but
that's wrong also because i still
remember 93
94 eric clapton did a tour
and the [__] did
blues
and people were running out of the arena
throwing their tickets up in the air
they were mad because they didn't do
layla or he didn't do [__] you know i
shot the sheriff so when you go for
change sometimes
when you go for change sometimes people
don't like it but you got to stick to
your [__] guns
and then they'll like it no one of the
things one of the smartest things that
you taught me because i talked to a lot
of people about their podcast
is
you can't
you can you can look at trends you can
look at what people like and work to
that but you can't ask them what they
want or do only what they want because
they'll get bored with it
and
and you got to do what you want and
hopefully the people who are supposed to
find it will find it
and
and you'll be happy there's no there's
no point in doing something if you're
just pandering and you don't even like
what you're doing
no but i see now from not being in la as
a comic
i see other comics
doing the podcast
and them saying what you want to hear
i could see it now that i'm out of it i
could see that now
i could see uh
i just see a lot of things that
listen i am who i am and i'm rough and
tumbling i'm going to say whatever comes
to my mind you learned that over the
[__] 10 years then oh yeah you're not
sure listen they're going to be mad one
thing about you that i always loved was
like
tell these [__] people i love when
they say hey
make sure you put this guy on the
podcast that's the last guy i'm putting
on the [__] podcast
when you guys give me a recommendation
at home like put this guy on the podcast
that's the last [__] i'm putting
on
yeah no unless i think of it myself i'm
not putting this [__] on when
you guys send me weird messages you ever
get a weird message sent back to you
from me like that you can't understand
that's all done purposely
like you'll call me and say are you
going to be in phoenix thursday through
sunday can i do a guest spot
i'll say there was a fire at my house
and my cat got killed i'll call you next
week yeah and you're like what the [__]
i just asked him about a spot and he
told me about his dead cat
that's what i've been doing for years
i will not put a guest on the show
because you want me to put a guest on
the show i will not talk about something
because you want me to talk about like
every monday morning after a fight
people go can you please talk about
this situation you know if i find it
fit to talk about i'll talk about it but
if i know rogan's gonna do it better
why would i even try
exactly rogan's got that fight down to a
science if you think i'm gonna come on
here and try to go hand to hand with
rogan on his knowledge of fighting and
boxing and [__] i'm not gonna do it i
might give you my take on it just you
know from what i'm thinking that we
should discuss it like i did with conor
mcgregor and with jon jones last week
which
i got to pull my john jones podcast back
because jesus christ i didn't know what
he had done
yeah i had no [__] idea what he had
done i just thought that john
i love john
i [__] love jon jones i love when he
talks to me i like being around him he's
a fun guy he's filled with energy but
i think this guy he this time he hit it
on the head when he said he has to stop
drinking
because of the trauma his brain got i
think that's real
remember when we had big john mccarthy
on the podcast
right oh yeah of course they told us
that he thinks that oj
killed his wife but he didn't [__]
remember like he couldn't even
because of the cte like you know cte is
a [__] and when you throw
cocaine and alcohol on ct
that's like giving an indian gin you
know you're just looking for [__]
problems there so
i gotta recap my little john jones
podcast from last week because i love
john
but i think what he did last week was a
little out of bounds for john i think
that yeah they released the 911 tape and
i couldn't listen to it was it bad i
couldn't i just i didn't i don't want it
i don't want to listen to it i don't
want to listen to it i feel bad for john
and i wish that he gets it together
because once it comes into your house
that's when it's bad that's when the
next one's going to be bad
once it comes into your house when
you're doing [__] that's on the street
it's one [__] thing
but once it comes into your house your
three kids witnessed it your two kids
whatever
then it gets real so i wish them all the
luck in the world from
uncle joey's joint and the [__]
church you know what i'm saying
[__] you know what again i'll be
looking for
you know what i
i'm i have a couple of things i'm i'm i
uh
i'm talking with some people who
who can like use my podcasting knowledge
i i really i would love to figure out a
way to to help
podcasters
interact with sponsors better i
the thing that i was always frustrating
at the beginning of podcasting was
everyone had the same
hulu plus blue apron and those are the
great companies and it's great that they
believe in the the medium
but
it's really
i feel like it's
it still has a long way to go
because
like to get and i know that they tip in
their tone a little bit but to get
coca-cola in there to get to really like
one of the one of the coolest things
that i got to do it was very small i
just did the introduction you closed the
deal but tushy was just i was like you
kept talking about bidets
and i was like let me look for bidets
and i found them and i wrote them an
email and then you guys figured
everything out and they're a great
company to work with but i think what
podcasting
offers that
people don't really understand
is it's not just an ad people fast
forward through hopefully or
or are missing anymore is if the when
the host or the podcast has a real
connection it's like why ari doesn't
have expedia as a sponsor
like like stuff like that like stuff
that really connects i think is is
missing so i'm hoping to find something
that's where my thought is right now
you know what's crazy lee you
more than everybody anybody know
that i have a process for sponsors
i don't really want to
put something out there that i don't
believe it
absolutely
and then we step it up a little more
i don't want to put something out there
that i don't use
you know
we have uh the bong company today
we have draftkings today
and we have on it today
yep i use all three of them
and i'm very happy with all three of
them
[__] draftkings you know you could
create a profile on draftkings
until people follow you
and follow your picks and you could
create a community on draftkings that's
i see i'm so jealous that i can't i can
use draftkings for like the daily
fantasy but i can't in massachusetts you
can't do the sports betting it doesn't
sound like it's betting yet
only in states like jersey where it's
legal right so so that's it's uh i i
would love to do that i'm all i'm
jealous
heart watching your reads and get it
getting to do that but that's awesome
that you get to follow me
i love my products i really love my
products when i was with the surgery
and i still do i use that cbd lion tape
when i go to the gym if half those
products you always see those products
are diminishing there's a reason
there's a reason because i'm [__]
using them
you know
i mean and that was something that you
taught me
because like so people would reach out
and have like competing sponsors and
you'd be like i'm not going to do it how
am i going to go one week and go with
company x that does the same thing and
two weeks later i'm doing company y i
lose credibility
it's uh
it's i
i really do think like we we got it not
even at the beginning but
over 10 years ago i think there's so
much that podcasts can offer it's funny
that one of the after all the fun lease
on outer space everything that we did on
the church the comment that i get the mo
almost the most is my argument with joe
about
audio is the future me high as [__] not
really being able to make sense
but five six years later he he's with
spotify and i really do
honestly believe in this medium i think
i think it brings something that that is
missing right now
i love it but it's about to change again
after it's always changing like i think
it's gonna change again and that's what
i like about it the most that i think
it's gonna
we're looking at something that's about
to change again
something's going to pop up with this
pretty soon like its own channel
a better way to do it like i i'm loving
these zooms
i'm loving these zooms
uh this would have saved us if they
could
make the zoom a little better
maybe if they could able to smell our
farts
like if i could fart in a [__]
canister and you could smell it at home
it would add to it or if they could
smell the reefer
or something you know but the podcast
realm is going to change
you know it's a shame that i'm getting
older you know uh
my thoughts are a little old i had a lot
of young guys like i had that
really good age group 21 to 32 whatever
you know but now i'm not smoking pot on
here you know i'm doing so many things i
wanted to change you know i didn't want
to come back with the same old [__]
song and dance even though it is the
same old [__] song and dance it's
just you know you just try to be honest
with people this is the same [__]
song and dance we just try to make a
little bit more uh
you know fresher is what i'm trying to
but i feel that this is about to change
any [__] day now
yeah it's been i mean when we started it
was all
people talking having fun now companies
are doing
like full-on productions they have
actors they have they have seasons espn
has them companies are starting to have
them
and
it's it's always it's always changing
and that's that's what's so fun about
and that's like with you like yeah i
mean there are some aspects of the joint
that are similar to the church but even
though even though you are a very um
you know
you you're not set in your ways but you
have the ways you are you have your
beliefs and you stick to them but
something that you do do is you you
evolve you you change
when when you're done with something
you're done with it and it's it's uh it
would be i think it'd be disingenuous if
like you jumped on there smoking joints
on the podcast and then as soon as the
podcast ended you never smoked like you
when you were smoking on the church that
was
just you smoking
all day it was just you changed it was
who i was so i don't want to
misinterpret who i am to these people at
home now because we change
we evolve as human beings listen i
didn't want i could have came back here
and gone up to new york or
hudson county and got a state-of-the-art
studio
and done all this [__] and only i
thought about it and i gotta be honest
with you i'm not sold on all that high
level [__]
i still like this to feel like pirate
radio
i still want this to feel like i'm doing
something wrong like the cops could
knock on my door at any time and go hey
what are you doing you're not supposed
to be doing this like this is
what i wanted to do i could have got a
fancy studio with lights and six guys
bringing you coffee and
that that's not what a podcast is
supposed to be that's radio
yep a podcast supposed to be something
that if
the sound is a little muffled we're not
worried about it
right there's a sound of an ambulance
we're not worried about it because it's
not memorex it's [__] live
right before
people is it live no it's memorex now
u.n memories could suck my dick
it's live
people i don't want memorix no more i
don't know if you've ever seen it one of
my favorite it's a meme i guess it's a
picture of people like it's like this is
a podcast and it's one guy sitting next
to a billboard but like the people on
the billboard look all look like they're
talking and it's one guy just sitting
next to it like he's part of the
conversation
what i loved about about our podcast and
your podcast is
it's almost like me like i'm an
introverted guy i don't talk much
it's like
we're having a conversation and and
you're doing
most of the talking it's it's not
it's not pre-scripted it's not like you
you
are doing stuff just to make a laugh
it's it's honestly it's like almost like
a journal it's like your audio journal
is the way i look at your podcast
and
you you have points and you have
thoughts that i mean you're you're one
of the most prepared people i ever met
you have a notebook i'm sure you have a
notebook right in front of you no i'm
today no no no no no okay
but i mean it's that's that's the way i
view this as like some people are
different and i love other podcasts that
aren't are
have themes or whatever but i i view
yours as an audio journal that's what i
think that's what it was supposed to be
from day one
yep that's what it's supposed to be from
day [__] one
you know it's not supposed to be fancy
lights and drum rolls and [__] like that
it's just supposed to be
two three six morons talking you know
that wasn't supposed i could watch john
oliver if i want graphics
you know what i'm saying i mean that's
what i think that i even do an injustice
to youtube uh to podcast with youtubing
like i was telling mike i'm thinking a
taping podcast like bill burr and just
putting a picture up on youtube
they don't have to see anything you know
no more they don't have to see it
this was created for you to listen for
you to start listening again
this is what i wanted this is why i
loved
putting out cds and albums
oh yeah i [__] hate specials i
[__] hated him that's why i was bad
at him i didn't enjoy him a cd is how i
was introduced to comedy not a cd per se
but an album that skipped
that bounced a little bit your uncle
left it out in the sun one day he went
to get milk and he left the album in the
car and the sun bent it a little bit so
now when i hear it it's actually doing
like a boom boom but like i like that
and that's what i wanted for the podcast
world uh even the people at home
to be going shh
i don't want my mom to hear it like that
[__]
that's what i always saw the podcast as
so
who the [__] knows we this is what you
see it as and this is what we want it to
grow as and uh
i'm happy you took the time today to
come on and talk some [__] with me i was
sick and tired of being doing these
serious [__] podcasts it's time for a
goofy podcast you know what i'm saying
shoving whipped cream of people's
[__]
oh no i love it it's uh it's always
great to talk to you man it's always
there's no one who can make me laugh and
smell like even even when you said that
like like my cheeks still hurt it's just
like there's you say that you're taking
a break from comedy but in reality
you're just taking a break from going on
stage you're still i'm taking a break
from going on stage i just
there's no one who talks like you think
it's it's uh
and that's why the podcast is great
because i mean you say you're getting
old i don't think you're that old yet
but i mean this the [__] that you can
say
on podcast you can you're in your house
what's better than that who wants to
drive an hour to sit in traffic have
people cough on you someone's pulled
over to the side you come downstairs you
do your 45 minutes an hour and you get
to go up and
color whatever you're gonna do that's it
that's it
i haven't colored in a while [__]
i don't know she's not she's done
coloring
uh she's still colors i just there's no
pandemic so she don't want me in the
room coloring with her no more you know
i'm saying that okay that was when she
was supposed to be in school we would
color she was coloring the other day she
asked me i
i just found some of the pictures i used
to color i got a whole folder i must
have colored a thousand pictures during
that [__] pandemic weather but ever
since we moved here
she colors in her room she colors at
school she don't color here with me no
more she's getting big
she doesn't i go in her room once in a
while but i don't sit in there i go in a
room to talk to her and [__]
i tell her to clean her room but i don't
sit in there it's not as big as the room
in l.a
i don't even think she has a chair in
this room no i just sit on the bed
it's that's what it was upstairs i'm
happy you're doing well you look great
thank you i'm trying uh i'm happy that
everything's working out for you i'm
happy that you're loving that [__] i
told you it was like a hershey kiss
it's the best smelling [__] you'll ever
smell you know what i'm saying [__]
smells bad but sometimes that [__]
just smells good
now i have i haven't done i haven't gone
into it yet i just i just stay on the
outside
you haven't put your tongue into the
shaft
no no that's the true vaccine right
there how do you get it in how do you
like push it through that you just
you just keep pushing your tongue in
and then if not you you loosen it with a
finger just the tip it's like the
thimble
yeah like just the thimble of the finger
and you open it up it's like a shoe
what do you call it a shoehorn you know
what i'm saying just enough to get the
[__] tongue in your [__]
and then you go in and then you machine
gun it
it's like you have to go in and out
though not like
the [__] is up and down like a snake
like a rattlesnake right like
the machine gun in the [__] is like
this
and then you see what happens the tongue
is folded so when it goes into the
[__] it opens up it's a [__]
surprise it's like a [__] fortune
cookie of love you know what i'm saying
just in their [__]
you can't lick the [__] and lick the
[__] because the [__] will get sick
off and [__] yeah it's [__] [__] you
can't go [__] to [__] what do you
have to do listerine in between cause
i've done that i didn't know that was
the thing yeah you might get a [__] six
you might get
the club the clip might cough and [__]
you'll hear it when you before you bite
into it real hard you know what i'm
saying like a piece of calamari
you bite into that [__] [__] and
you're sniffing at the same time
i i i laughed thinking about you the
other day because she was like oh i want
to take a shower i just thought about
you always saying like i like a little
bit of onion
get that [__] get that little hairy
monkey out here with that greek tzatziki
sauce on the monkey
and let's get that party started jack
that tzatziki sauce when it's got that
little oniony small to the [__] and if
it don't happen at the beginning just
keep finger two finger louie
and eventually you'll hit eureka and
that [__] wang will come out of there
you'll smell their kidney their liver
their intestines that's when you know
you hit [__] rock bottom jack you
know what i'm saying
i love that oh my god that's actually my
jack i went out for a ride and i never
came back you know what i'm saying
your dad's not coming back leave me
alone that's not coming back leave me
alone you ugly [__]
i told you this go practice baseball no
one day he left
go practice your swings no one day left
[__] sucker
you know your [__] chicken you didn't
eat your [__] nuggets
now you won you want to knock on the
door mommy give me breakfast go [__]
yourself you little [__]
oh go watch the discovery channel what's
up make believe you're eating a sandwich
[__] women with kids what a [__]
pain he is
oh my god hysterical my cheeks hurt oh
my god oh my god i love it oh my god
oh my god
i love you [__] i love you too
buddy thank you for having me
anytime i'm friends stay black always a
pleasure to see you give my best to mom
and dad
i will tell dad i said hello give him an
extra edible to [__] him up out of
respect
oh yeah we're gonna have fun this
weekend
all right stay black buddy thank you for
coming on uncle joe he's joined
of course buddy thank you bye
bye
what's happening twinkle toes i hope you
enjoyed the [__] episode
you know it's always great to see him
like i said we're still [__] tired
and [__]
shoe leather we still chitchat from time
to times i miss them we didn't have them
on last month
because of a different agenda but i
promise i'd have them on today no two no
two episodes all we need is just one to
[__] get the party started so i hope
you enjoyed it uh
i also want to congratulate michael
myself and you guys it's a one-year
anniversary since we started the joint
so
thank you for watching today thank you
for being part of it i know we had some
rocky [__] moments here
but uh we're back up running you know
we're still not a hundred percent but we
will be in the next couple weeks
don't forget about laughing gas it's
available and ready to [__] go and
stronger than ever i should be getting
my next batch next week
and beside that that's it you bad
[__] you know uncle joey loves
you i hope you enjoyed the podcast have
a great weekend i want to thank
draftkings i want to thank [__]
uh freeze pipe i want to thank me undies
i want to thank cbd lion i want to thank
honett for always having our back and i
want to thank you guys because you're
the best in the business stay black have
a great weekend and now for a word from
my [__] sponsor jack
all right [__] i love you guys
with all my heart i want to thank lee
i want to thank draftkings freeze pipe
on it i want to thank michael it's our
one year anniversary most importantly i
want to thank you guys for always having
our back the joint is brought to you by
freeze pipe
nothing makes you feel like a bigger
loser when you [__] cough in front of
your friends and half your [__] teeth
and your lung comes out
freeze pipe is here to turn all that
[__] around
freeze pipe is tremendous
smoking weed doesn't have to hurt your
lungs guys
for years i've been putting ice in a
bong and smoking in the snow like in
colorado with freeze pipe you can get an
icy cold hit every [__] time
it comes with a detachable chamber you
freeze beforehand here's how it works
the smoke passes through the frozen part
and cools down the smoke as you inhale
it's like putting ice cubes in a bong
but better it's non-toxic it freezes
water freezes faster than water and it
stays frozen longer freeze pipe cools
down the smoke by hundreds of degrees
whether you hit a pipe a bubbler a bong
or a dab
they got it all i've got the bubbler
over here and i [__] love it you
could smoke from it freeze pipe makes it
a lot [__] better you understand me
this is the bong you've been waiting for
take it from the expert of [__]
reefer this is the bong for you go to
freezepipe.com right now
press and code joey and i'm gonna get
you 10 off your first order whether you
get the bong the pipe or the bubbler i'm
not going to let you down this is the
pipe you've been waiting for that's
freezepipe.com
press code joey and save 10
and go into the murky waters the joint
is also brought to you by
from the heart of [__] new jersey
draftkings listen it's week five of
football and you're still sitting there
scratching your head
most pros don't wait till week five to
put their [__] bets in
the raiders played monday night whatever
happened there but now we got a whole
new week and draftkings is ready the
official sports betting partner of the
nfl they're reliable they're consistent
and you can withdraw your money whenever
the [__] you want i'm looking forward to
the ufc this week i'm looking forward to
thursday night's game but it all starts
tonight with the dodgers against the
saint louis cardinals but listen to this
you can put in your bet tonight but
draftkings has an offer that's [__]
crazy they're giving all new customers
ready for this and you're new 150 when
you bet a dollar on any nfl football
game that's it but you also got [__]
baseball you got the nba starting on the
18th this is the season [__] to
make some money you heard me you
[__] head to draftking sportsbook
app now today download the draftking
sportsbook app bet a dollar and get 150
in free bets instantly now gambling
isn't for you you don't like sports i
get it it's the sports book isn't for
you draftking still has huge cash prizes
up for grabs all season long with that
daily fantasy contest however you play
draftkings is giving all new customers a
free shot at a million dollars
draftkings fantasy is real my friends
love it i don't play fantasy i'm more of
a sportsbook type of guy but whatever
you are draftkings has you covered get
ready to win some money download the
draftking sportsbook app today use promo
code joey to get 150
and free bets when you place a dollar
bet
on any football game it's that easy
use promo code joey
at this week's draftking sports book the
official sports betting partner of the
nfl now new jersey indiana pennsylvania
west virginia colorado only new
customers only
minimum five dollar deposit to make a
one dollar wager that's easy as [__] one
per customer restrictions do apply see
draftkings.com sportsbook for details if
you got a gammon pump take care of it
call 1-800 gambler or if you're in
indiana call 1-800
with it
but if you're not if you're solid
download the draftking sportsbook app
today and let's win some guinness and it
starts tonight with st louis and the
dodgers will go tomorrow night the nfl
football and then sadly you got the ufc
college
football and then rolling into sunday
you got football and baseball playoffs
who's better than you nobody the joint
is also brought to you by one of my
personal favorites on it whether it's
the alpha brain shroom tech shroom tech
immune shroom tech sport
new mood the mct
kettle bells on it's got it all go to
haunted.com right now
read look at all the products and
supplements they had i can't help you
out with the club bats and i can't help
you out with the kettlebells but when it
comes to supplements uncle joey's got
your back [__]
go down
start with bla start with the alpha
brain start with the black label listen
they got 100 money back guarantee if you
don't like alpha braid you can keep the
product and they'll send you the money
back who else believes in their product
like that
nobody [__] so go to honor.com
right now
press it on checkout
and save yourself 10 percent delivered
right to your house i want to thank
annette
i want to thank freeze pipe and i want
to thank draftkings
and i want to thank you [__]
for making this the best week that you
can i love you [__] i'll see you
next week
tip top magoo on monday
morning stay black uncle joey loves you
so
[Music]
you